es geht ihm wieder gut kreml-kritiker
alexej nawalny wurde vor wenigen stunden
aus der berliner charité entlassen in
einem tweet des krankenhauses heißt es
alexej nawalny ist gestern aus der
stationären behandlung entlassen wurden
der gesundheitszustand des patienten hat
sich so weit gebessert dass die akute
medizinische behandlung beendet werden
konnte
der prominente kreml-kritiker war am 20
august im sibirischen tomsk vergiftet
worden und befand sich seitdem im koma
für eine bessere ärztliche versorgung
wurde navalny am 22
august aus russland nach berlin geflogen
und in die charité klinik eingeliefert
nach navalny seien lieferungen hatte ein
bundeswehr labor zweifelsfrei einer
vergiftung mit einem nervengift aus der
nordgruppe nachgewiesen später wurden in
seinem hotelzimmer kontaminierte wasser
flaschen gefunden
russland weist bis jetzt eine
beteiligung an der vergiftung zurück am
7 september hatte alexej nawalny sich so
weit erholt dass die deutschen ärzte
beschlossen ihn langsam ins leben
zurückzuholen kurze zeit später postete
er mit seiner familie bilder aus dem
krankenbett und bei seinen ersten
gehversuchen alexej nawalny ist frei
sitzt an einem sicheren ort er will
zurück nach russland
hier ist er nicht sicher denn putins
agenten sind auch in berlin
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren